[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh Zeus dieu des dieux nous vous
implorons pour le salut du Liss voilà 20
ans que sa femme Pénélope l'attend avec
une vertu qui l'honore
accueille la reine ça fait 10 ans que tu
nous fais attendre tu dois choisir en
roice que tu veux de moi à ton
avisas pas h Laer ton peup crever de fa
ti ta promesse
martoiir
[Musique]
j c'est toi qui devra être roi
si tu étais roi je ne craindrai plus
rien tout le temps avec toi montre à
tous que tu es le plus fort et tu ce qui
te défie c'est tu le prir que te tuant
je n'attendrai pas toute ma vie aide mon
fils temar et donneelui la force de son
père tuas plus de Dieu plus droit plus
d'Agora tuas plus de nous une voie n
connu s'approche d'itac la voile est
bleue comme celle
d'uliss gloire à notre père
est enfin revenu chez
[Musique]
lui et
l'abondance je
[Musique]
prutoris à vouloir prendre ma
place jeis Leme c'est toi qui a changé
une grave accusation a été lancé contre
notre re a de SP pourzevenir les
mazoublé la méoire de vos pr à
FAM
tuorter ton Roum dans le
sang
TR debarquer avec son armé c'est la
guerre
is ton peuple t'attend
toujours